will you say it around the world with me  a draft wait a pg-13 been to so many  places what's it like signing up their  own life miserable  you're either sunburned sleep-deprived  or seasick and after a few days there's  that loosen Asians why do you do it it's  a fear it's intense wish you and  infinite horizon we must be a sailor - I  take it I don't know that I would  consider myself a sailor oh come on no  you are what you want to say Carl  anytime you think you might wanna do it  sayin it mean  [Music]  how would you like to sail it has ended  a California verse four thousand miles  is insane I'm saying with me  [Music]  hurricane Raymond has been upgraded to a  category 5  I love you  [Music]  [Applause]  I'm gonna die out here  you